this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up guys helen here you don't have
to be choking down an herbalife protein
shake while wearing a buttery soft pair
of lularoe leggings to know that
multi-level marketing is everywhere you
may associate mlms with your facebook
friend ash linden the homecoming queen
who got married young and now slides
into your dms with business
opportunities but globally 100 million
households buy into an mlm every year
and at any given moment one in six
american households are under contract
with one of these companies and trust us
they would love to make you their next
recruit and yes dunking on mlms has
become something of a pastime you've
seen john oliver's eviscerating expose
on last week tonight or perhaps listen
to the podcast the dream but just in
case you're still debating whether or
not to take a second mortgage out on
your home in order to buy a wholesale
supply of protein bars let us be crystal
clear mlms are categorically a scam
statistically you're more likely to
profit from gambling in a casino than
from joining an mlm that said today
we're not going to regurgitate every
point about this icky industry no matter
how alarming and valid those points may
be instead we're going to ask why have
mlms become such a mainstay of the
global economy and what does it say
about us both as people and a society
i'm scared to learn the answer but sure
let's explore in this wisecrack edition
how mlms took over the world but before
we dive in i want to talk about this
week's sponsor surfsharkvpn
surfsharkvpn's uncrackable encryption
and secure protocols help keep your data
secure as you click around the internet
there are so many upsides to using a
secure vpn like surfshark but one perk
of using it is that the internet can't
determine where in the world i am and
that opens up a world of possibility i
can stream movies and tv from other
countries and whenever i'm in the mood
to even visit another country i can make
sure i get the best price on my plane
tickets how because i can avoid
location-based price discrimination by
connecting my secure surfshark vpn to
other vpns in different countries until
i discover the best deal with just one
subscription all of your favorite
devices are covered we're talking about
your laptop android playstation and xbox
amazon firestick and beyond and you'll
find options for your favorite apps too
like firefox and chrome so get started
today by clicking the link in the
description and using the promo code
wisecrack and starting on november 1st
you can get surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus
four extra months for free this deal
goes until december 31st so be sure to
check it out go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show now to understand the power
of mlms it helps to know where they came
from the basic mlm model was first
invented and implemented by an unlikely
trio of men in the early 1940s a failed
entrepreneur a radio show psychologist
and a salesman turned sales manager for
the world's fanciest cemetery a real
holy trinity of dudes you wouldn't want
to sit next to on a cross-country flight
each of these men is um unique first
we've got failed entrepreneur carl
renberg who banked his fortunes on
selling evaporated milk to the
burgeoning 1920s chinese market despite
the fact that the culture's cuisine used
almost no dairy after a couple more
failed businesses he put processed
alfalfa sprouts into a capsule called it
a vitamin and then desperately tried and
failed to sell it via his company
neutralite also in this bro squad we
have radio show psychologist william s
casselberry who wrote books with dubious
titles like how to work miracles in your
life the golden secret of successful
living hurting for money castleberry
signed on to become a salesman for
renborg's neutralite but the most
interesting player has gotta be lee
meitinger door to door salesman turned
sales manager for los angeles forest
lawn cemetery which is only a few miles
from wisecrack's world headquarters
today your decaying body can still find
rest in this fancy-ass burial ground and
we hope you love it there but heads up
that you will be surrounded by an art
museum gift shop and reproductions of
classic italian statues that have a
penchant for randomly toppling to the
ground my tinker's job might seem
innocuous in a modern day context after
all the funeral process is really
[ __ ] expensive no matter where you
live but prior to 1920 most people used
to get their burial plots at a low cost
or via donation from churches or other
non-profits that is until entrepreneurs
sent hordes of direct door-to-door
salesmen to peddle yoga mat-sized chunks
of land to people who were well not dead
yet and when someone had actually died
these salesmen would often exploit the
grief of family members they'd do things
like pressuring them to do right by
their dead relatives by investing in
expensive funeral costs now it's not
like people woke up one day wanting to
spend thousands of dollars on their
final resting place so the more than 100
cemetery salesmen that my tinker managed
had a very specific and very ambitious
job
they had to create a widespread want and
need for a product that nobody had asked
for they weren't responding to natural
consumer demand they were providing a
supply of something people were used to
getting for cheap and or free
but my tinker was annoyed by one aspect
of his job description training salesmen
who would eventually get promoted to
manager once promoted he stopped earning
commission off of their sales let alone
anybody they managed meintenger dreamed
of creating a business model that would
allow him to continue to profit off of
his underlying success he envisioned a
world where i keep the income from the
people i develop so cemetery guy and the
radio psychologist met in a
self-improvement course and became best
buds in 1943 they developed the plan
which they brought to their vitamin
buddy renborg the plan was a new way for
him to market and sell his alfalfa
capsules this plan detailed the nuts and
bolts of multi-level marketing aka a
recruitment-based direct sales force and
this alfalfa sprout has sprouted mlms as
we know them today faced with an
unremarkable item that nobody wanted to
buy our trio did something savvy they
created a fake demand by recruiting a
growing army of salespeople who had to
buy a stockpile of vitamins they would
then try and fail to sell and those 1940
sales people were spurred on by all the
same promises you hear today endless
revenue possibilities becoming a small
business owner working flexible hours
and so on and if they recruited some
unsuspecting friends they'd be paid a
pretty penny for their trouble the
company had a standard five get five
plan in which each member starting with
founders was tasked with recruiting five
new salespeople so you get commission
for everyone you recruit and everyone
your recruits recruit and so on this
might seem innocuous at its face but
pull out a calculator and you'll quickly
see that this process can only last for
approximately 13 rounds before you need
to recruit more than the entire
population of the planet according to
multi-level marketing critic robert
fitzpatrick and there's every reason to
believe the founders of the first mlm
knew that the exponential growth plan
was entirely unsustainable in fact one
of these clowns even joked that everyone
on earth would eventually be selling the
product and in a way it worked
nutrilite's revenue grew by an
astounding fifty thousand percent in
just nine years
of course that revenue under the plan
mostly flew to the top four percent of
the food chain those who had recruited
early on and now had thousands of people
beneath them it was less people earning
money and more a transfer of wealth from
the bottom 96 to those at the top then
in the late 50s two seasoned neutral
light salesmen left and formed a new mlm
amway which sold basic household items
like detergent and body wash these dudes
one of whom birthed betsy devos's
husband didn't merely carbon copy the
model they brought in god as fitzpatrick
puts it amway turned earning money into
a moral crusade by promising wealth as a
salvation and proclaiming failure as a
sin
that is to say good christians sell soap
and lots of it it's no wonder that one
sociologist called amway a
quasi-religious corporation for its
success at grafting commercialism onto
existing models of evangelical
christianity as fitzpatrick elaborates
amway's moral tone and christian
rhetoric blended inexplicably with
patriotism and capitalism were adopted
by many mlms that followed christian
churches became hotbeds of mlm
recruiting with clergy in the uplines
that's right your pastor might be trying
to sell you on a lucrative opportunity
involving laundry detergent and
importantly many of history's most
successful mlms today sell products like
face creams vitamins and diet pills and
these just so happen to be products
known for their reliance on questionable
marketing claims which encourage the
same magical thinking that gets people
to join mlms in the first place so now
that we know where mlms came from it's
worth asking how do they get millions of
people to join and more bafflingly how
do they get people to stay in an
economic opportunity that's
mathematically destined to fail let's
investigate via amway the big daddy of
mlms amway exploded during the economic
downturn of the mid-1970s it was a time
of stagflation the destruction of unions
the privatization of social safety nets
and so on this environment created the
perfect conditions for mlms to seem like
an enticing opportunity amway's success
would only intensify in the buzzy
consumer-happy decades to come so it
doesn't sound that hard to make people
join after all as human beings we're
wired for low effort high reward
prospects just ask your great uncle who
buys five lottery tickets every week but
let's say you're intrigued by an mlm how
do they get you to stay once you've
learned that it's hell on earth it's
simple they take over your life that's
according to steven butterfield a former
amway salesperson who wrote a tell-all
book about their practices according to
him amway slowly but surely takes over
every aspect of your existence your
upline recruiter convinces you to give
up outside friends and hobbies there's
also low-key brainwashing for instance
amway convinces you to buy expensive
motivational tapes recorded by the
company's founders and tells you to
listen to them every day this practice
is what fitzpatrick describes as
pseudo-psychological self-improvement
programs this makes sense because mlms
don't actually offer tangible economic
rewards to their participants so they
have to like cemetery salesmen sell
people on an idea as fitzpatrick puts it
mlms seek to capture the mind of the
recruit money will follow the more they
believe and the longer they believe the
more money the company gets from them
and once they get you to buy in they
keep you by exerting increasing control
over your choices as butterfield
explains you follow your recruiter's
advice on everything from how to cut
your hair to what kind of motorhome you
should buy he details the various
bonkers advice that mlm leaders offer on
things like marriage sexual practices
and how to raise your children we see a
similar ethos reflected in current mlms
most notably lularoe we were
supposed to be empowered at first and
then the husband was supposed to take
over
and like other mlms amway also demands
all of your time as butterfield notes
emily and sis distributors work five to
six nights a week on recruitment and
sustaining their business
they pump you up at creepy social events
where upwards of 10 000 people stand for
hours in the dark holding candles
shouting amway-themed chants butterfield
says that the events often go past
midnight and crowds pour out into the
streets at 3am still chanting their
mantras
[Music]
[Applause]
it's no wonder then that author amanda
montel argues that mlms are if not
straight-up cults at the very least
cultish for more on that check out our
recent video on the topic like a cult an
effective mlm subsumes the lives of
their members it reshapes their world
views and priorities and it threatens
serious social and economic
repercussions to anyone who even
considers leaving but maybe you're
thinking it's all worth it for the money
you're gonna make right um did you just
black out you absolutely will not profit
unless you invented the mlm or joined
right away you will lose money so there
you have it mlms are an almost
guaranteed economic loss and a very not
fun culty vibe so how have they survived
well importantly they've bought a [ __ ]
ton of political clout via their
gigantic direct marketing lobby check
out fitzpatrick's book ponzinomics for
an in-depth breakdown of that insane
story but for now we're gonna focus on
the culture and the psychology that has
sustained mlms because that seems just
as important as the government
corruption that's helped them along and
for that we'll need to jump back in time
again to the moment mlms appeared on the
scene the post-world war ii economic
boom this was approximately the same
time as the birth of the consumer-based
economy where increased production
capacity meant there was a lot more ship
being made and thus a lot more ship to
buy suddenly consumer behavior needed to
stop being entirely needs-based and
started becoming a whole lot more
wants-based so how do you get people to
watch they don't absolutely need you
sell them hard unsurprisingly the late
40s early 50s was also the birth of the
salesification of american society per
historian richard huber while sales was
once considered a separate occupation it
was rapidly becoming a way of life
america was becoming a nation of
salesmen at the same time sociologist c
wright mills concurred that the growing
influence of sales in this time meant
that in public and in private there is
the tang and feel of salesmanship
salespeople especially of the
door-to-door variety had once
constituted a specific small role in the
economy and were often derided as kind
of predatory but as companies had more
and more to sell sales got a major
rebrand and the explosion of advertising
pr marketing and so on meant that more
and more people's jobs were based around
getting people to buy more [ __ ] they
didn't need check out our how
advertising changed video for more on
that anyway that's why the emergence of
mlms at this moment in time makes
perfect sense multi-level marketing is
the logical conclusion of a sales-based
economy where everything revolves around
selling products then selling people on
the opportunity to themselves sell more
of these products but this as many a
tortured economist has held into the
wind doesn't make sense see the reason
80 of mlm recruits quit in the first
year is because mlms don't function
under rules of supply and demand they
grow not because of consumer demand but
by selling the members on the lie of
economic success then those people buy a
ton of the product to sell themselves
thus generating revenue for the company
after a while you've completely over
saturated any given area with
salespeople it's the equivalent of every
person who likes going to their local
wendy's subsequently opening a wendy's
on the same block because the cashier
was really [ __ ] charismatic but let's
set aside the irrationality the real
point is that the salesification of
society has normalized the interactions
you have over facebook with ash linden
as she tries one last time to get you to
come to her meal replacement soy shag
party in an mlm-led world the mix of
money and friendship no longer seems
strange according to fitzpatrick prior
to 1930 bringing up finances or
money-making with buddies wasn't super
kosher but he elaborates overall
reactions to these devious financial
intrusions into personal spheres of life
worship friendship family have declined
from mortal outrage to mere annoyance or
grudging tolerance for many others there
is no longer any boundary at all and to
us that's what's most nefarious about
mlms besides you know the bankruptcy
clinical depression divorce and overall
despair that the industry's been known
to cause because on a socio-cultural
level mlms obliterate the line between
markets and private life family members
and customers friends and employees in
doing so they essentially reduce all
human relationships to transactions
butterfield wrote as much saying amway
begins to change your life the first
time you approach your friends and
family members to sell them the products
or recruit them into the business
hitherto you related with them as friend
brother sister son daughter now you're
relating as a salesperson to a customer
friendship is no longer primary it is a
means to the end according to him once
you recruit a friend to an mlm your
relationship becomes a completely
prefabricated business association in
which honest friendship gradually
becomes impossible this is almost too
fitting for our weird era of late
capitalism where everything is a
commodity and every person a brand with
potential to peddle that commodity and
above all mlms work at an almost lizard
brain level exploiting the most american
belief that all you need to succeed is
an opportunity hard work and dedication
and on the flip side if you fail to
succeed it's on you now obviously this
is a myth that has become increasingly
untrue over recent decades work hours
and productivity are way up while wealth
is down for most folks by every metric
if mlms were somewhat delusional for our
grandparents in the 50s for us they're a
downright fairy tale where nobody
becomes a princess in the end and not in
a subversive shrek way either i'm
supposed to be beautiful
you are beautiful and in this way mlms
aren't that different from the american
economy at large which assures us that
hard work will be rewarded with high pay
or that an expensive college degree will
yield a steady lifestyle or that home
ownership will equate to lifelong
security mlms are just an exaggerated
almost cartoonish form of this toothless
myth they offer riskier opportunities
make bolder promises and screw you over
even more and i'm also having to claim
bankruptcy in this way they're an almost
too perfect distillation of a society
that over-promises under-delivers and
then blames you for your problems but
what do you guys think after everything
you've heard are you still interested in
starting your own small business where
you pick up your own hours and are your
own boss if so please let me know in my
twitter dms because boy do i have an
opportunity for you big thanks to our
patrons for all your support and don't
forget to check out our podcast hit that
subscribe button like you're emptying
your bank account to buy a lifetime
supply of plant fertilizer and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you